historically it is private industry that
has made life better not really
government
that's the stuff we should be focusing
on we should want more of this not less
than this
come on jeffrey you can do it pave the
way put your back into
it tell us why show us how look at where
you came from look at you now
yesterday something very cool happened
to jeff bezos who of course is the owner
of amazon founder of amazon he went up
into space
is a very very cool thing right this is
a unique
moment in human history when we have
moved beyond
simple governments taking human beings
to space we now have two separate
billionaires in the past two weeks
who have gone into either very very low
space or into slightly higher space and
elon musk is planning
to go into full orbit and the idea here
is to eventually privatize space travel
which would be super duper cool i mean
it's a really neat thing
here's a little bit of the video of blue
origin this is the
jeff bezos rocket firing him and a
couple of friends into space
yeah you can see uh the dr evil style
phallic rocket flying directly up
into space it would have been good
aesthetically if they had made some
changes but
there it is it's uh flying into space
and that is pretty cool i mean
that is a human being who uh has um
you know a lot of money at stake as well
as his life going into space as a
civilian
and the idea here is going to be to
lower the price of space travel
down dramatically and that actually is
what is likely to happen here
according to reason.com there's every
reason to believe the democratization of
space travel is upon us bezos branson
elon musk have already delivered on that
promise in other sectors unless the
government manages to screw things up
following the pattern of commercial air
travel in the 20th century a novelty for
billionaires today may well be
accessible to the ordinary rich and then
to the middle class
soon enough also the billionaires say
they are taking a long-term view one day
the capacity to get off the planet
cheaply and at scale
could be humanity's salvation but it's
not just what they want or what they
envision that matters
you know we'll figure out as the market
evolves exactly what is important
about all of this i know that people
from spacex are openly talking about the
idea of building a moon base to mine
the moon for resources by the end of the
decade which is really super cool stuff
by the way they've already driven down
the cost of getting a kilogram into low
earth orbit by 44 fold because they're
building a competitive industry where
companies are actually competing to
lower the cost
on getting things into space and that
does matter for even things as
convenient as
your cell phone coverage satellite
coverage if you can get satellites into
space
more cheaply this is going to bring down
prices for a lot of technologies here on
earth
one thing that bezos was suggesting was
the ability to essentially fire
pollution
off earth right if there's heavy
industries that produce
for example nuclear waste and you have
no place to put that could you actually
just
throw that off into space
it doesn't really matter in other words
who gets to space first what does matter
is that we are
creating a very cool competitive
industry here and we are doing it with
private dollars which really does matter
that now this doesn't mean that the left
isn't mad about all this left is super
mad
about all of this because according to
the left all wealth is collectively
owned
so you have bernie sanders for example
tweeting out about this
he tweeted quote here on earth in the
richest country on the planet
half our people live paycheck to
paycheck people are struggling to feed
themselves struggling to see a doctor
but hey
the richest guys in the world are often
out of the space yes
it's time to tax the belgian as okay so
first of all
all net taxes in the united states all
net taxes in the united states after
transfer of government benefits
come from people who are very wealthy
all of them not some of them
all of them the notion that people at
the top end of the income bracket are
not paying their quote unquote fair
share is just a lie it is an overt and
silly lie and the reality is that if
bernie sanders really wanted to pay for
his vast blowout social programs he
would have to tax people at the same
rates that the tax people in the
scandinavian countries he so loves which
means radically increasing taxes on the
middle class which by the way bernie
sanders is not averse to doing
okay but jeff bezos pays a lot of taxes
he spends a lot of money
paying a lot of taxes and him using his
wealth in order to foster a brand new
industry is actually really cool because
here is the alternative
we could as a country spend vastly more
money than jeff bezos just spent in
order to do the exact same kind of stuff
by siphoning away your taxpayer dollars
how much money did it cost you
to send jeff bezos to space the answer
is it cost you no money
you bought products from amazon you
subscribed to amazon prime
in return you got value then he used the
profit that he derived from that to do
something cool that's number one none of
your business
number two something that actually does
benefit humanity i've said this over and
over and over
now bill gates has the bill gates
foundation he gives away hundreds of
millions of dollars
jeff bezos yesterday gave away like 200
million dollars
he has done more good for the world in
building amazon than in any of the
charity that he just gave
the reality is that in a free
functioning marketplace the stuff that
we
do together namely the transactions that
we engage in consensually
those are much more beneficial to us and
to the world at large than people simply
signing checks
which is something the left simply can't
fathom here's jeff bezos yesterday
saying this in in maybe the most awkward
possible way
he sort of suggested that everybody else
was paying for his flights of space
in one sense this is right in one sense
this is just a complete misspeak
i want to thank uh every
amazon employee and every amazon
customer
because you guys paid for all this so
seriously for every amazon customer out
there
and every amazon employee thank you from
the bottom of my heart very much
uh it's very appreciated okay in reality
did they actually pay for him to go to
space only in the sense that
when you buy something at the grocery
store you paid for the grocery store
owner's car
right they didn't pay for him to go to
space it wasn't like he just seized
their cash and then used it to go to
space
right he actually paid them a salary the
money from the amazon employees
only came from the extra productivity
that they create
because he is taking the risk of paying
them right okay but because people don't
understand economics this means that for
some odd reason they have a tendency to
trust the federal government
when they should not the reality is that
we should be trusting private industry
to do all the things that make life
better because
historically it is private industry that
has made life better not really
government
governments have existed since time
immemorial
governments all over planet earth have
existed forever the question is not
whether government
exists or whether government decides to
throw bread at the people as they did in
ancient rome the question is really
whether there are industries that
develop an economy strong enough to
actually make
products and services that are better
one of the great ironies of people like
bernie sanders complaining about
very rich people spending their money to
go to space is that bernie sanders is
very much in favor of the fact the
federal government has now seized and
siphoned away 22 trillion dollars in
wealth
over the course of the last 50 years in
order to reduce the poverty rate in the
united states by about zero
that doesn't bother him at all because
of course it is the high-minded use of
the money
that bernie sanders cares about more
importantly it's people like bernie
sanders controlling the flow of the
money that bernie sanders cares about
but the ancillary benefits of market
transactions that make the world better
that's the stuff we should be focusing
on we should want more of this not less
of this
if you ever want to be able to travel to
space it ain't going to be because the
federal government makes that possible
it is truly incredible that the same
people who are complaining about richard
branson and jeff bezos spending their
own money
to go to space and elon musk building a
space industry those same people are
like you know what we should do
technologically
if i had your money you know what i'd do
i'd build a high speed rail
monorail okay who do i trust the
monorail gang over here the people love
amtrak and just want to spend more money
on higher speed amtrak because we must
have
high rail a full-on 19th century
technology
you know from 250 years ago or should we
you know maybe focus in on the new
technologies
and more importantly allow people to
spend their own private wealth on that i
mean it's the coolest thing ever
it is excellent the private industry has
decided to advance
science and advance the the
possibilities of humankind this way
and that you don't have to pay for it
that's pretty damned awesome
so one of the great things about private
industry handling space travel is that
you don't
end up with the guns versus butter
discussions that you have to have at the
governmental level
after the united states sent a man to
the moon in 1969.
we basically started cutting the space
program right after that because there
are a bunch of people
on the left who said you know what we
don't need to go to the moon anymore
there's no purpose what do we care about
space we have enough problems here at
home
well when you have one taxpayer dollar
to spend and you have to decide whether
to buy off constituents
or whether to advance a science via nasa
usually it's a pretty easy call for
members of the political class
but the nice thing about private
industry is you don't control it so if
they decide to go do something ex
uber cool with regard to technology
whether it is developing cell phones
forwarding the internet or going to
space that is a zero cost
to you thing it is a value add
and the fact that people fail to
understand this is beyond me
understand that taxes are a way of
siphoning away from people
who are not harming you and are in fact
helping you with their development of
technology toward people
who simply want to buy votes with your
cash this is your this should be your
first suspicion when you hear people
like bernie sanders shout out about
taxing the billionaires who spends the
money better jeff bezos or bernie
sanders who's never on a popsicle stand
who's who do you think is going to be
forwarding the interests
of better products and better services
jeff bezos who literally has provided
millions of jobs across the globe and
provided a better life
for hundreds of millions of people i
mean i use amazon every day i'm sure so
do you
who do you think is going to better your
life more jeff bezos with money
or bernie sanders with money whose
entire history of spending money comes
down to buying lake houses with your
taxpayer dollars
who do you think i'm con honestly i'm
constantly shocked
at the fact that all these people who
yell at billionaires and millionaires
they think that the people who are best
positioned
to control the money are a bunch of
morons who have never run
a business it's it's it's beyond me
why would you like i wouldn't even trust
a businessman to run a business
where he has no level of expertise so
you're trusting people who have never
run a business
at all to handle your money and
determine where that money is going to
go
when you siphon money away from the
private sector and into the public
sector it becomes
less efficient when you take money away
from people who are entrepreneurial and
you put it in the hands of people whose
sole job it is
to buy off constituents and to create
particular dependent classes the money
is just gone
this is why we have seen slow growth in
the united states historically speaking
when you regulate business when you take
money away from business this is why we
are going to see after all of this
inflationary growth
after we see joe biden blow out
trillions of dollars
after we see this regulatory the
regulatory schemes he wants to put in
place
this is why even joe biden is predicting
the united states for the next decade is
going to grow at below a two percent gdp
rate
okay and yet joe biden's solution to
that take more money out of the private
sector
they support asking the wealthiest one
percent of americans of corporate
america
not to pay more than you just began to
pay their fair share just step up a
little bit
the idea that 50 largest corporations in
america
pay no tax ex i i think people should be
able to be
millionaires and billionaires if they
have the ideas but lord's sake
the idea let's start paying your fair
share
again it's just a lie that they're not
paying their fair share and number two
it's not about who's pa it just
demonstrates really that
in the end democratic policy is not it
really is not
about forwarding any sort of collective
good it is about punishing people who
are in wealth
i mean barack obama made this perfectly
clear in 2008 he was running for
president who specifically asked
if raising the capital gains tax rate
lowers
the amount of government revenue that is
brought in because people invest less
are you still for it and he said yes for
purposes of fairness
it is a childish mentality when it comes
to economics it's a childish mentality
when it comes to life
people who have more money than you are
not worse people than you and you are
not entitled to their money
most of us in fact will spend our lives
in different income brackets
most of us will spend our lives in the
bottom income bracket and the middle
income bracket maybe the top income
bracket maybe back to the middle income
bracket
year on year our incomes differ pretty
radically in fact if you want to look
at the factor that plays most into
wealth aggregation
it's age people get wealthier as they
get older because they have more asset
bases
they've spent more years in the
workforce and yet the notion seems to be
from the left that when billionaires
spend money in ways that you don't like
you should have control over that if
matthew miller who is an msnbc analyst
saying quote watching nasa take off when
i was a kid was such a moment of
national pride and unity
having them replaced by billionaire
vanity flights is one of the more
depressing touchstones of this era
this is the stupidest thing i've ever
heard so you're more proud when the
government
spends a bunch of your money to send
people to space than when you get to
watch an american
who built an american company and in the
process built literally hundreds of
thousands of american jobs
use that money in order to do the same
thing that nasa did except cheaper this
is what pisses you off
truly amazing stuff because honestly i
think in the end
what what so many people want is
government control it's the government
control is the excuse it is not that
they want government control because
they want a better life
it is not that they want government
control because they feel that
billionaires
are doing something nefarious with their
wealth there's nothing nefarious about
going to space
they want government control because
they believe that the government
will club the people they want clubbed
they believe that the government will
give them the things that they want
the government will do their bidding
it's
it's pretty insane really people need to
understand here's the way the basic
economics works
people who create new innovation people
who take risks people who spend their
own money taking those risks to produce
new goods and services in ways people
have not thought of it before those are
the people who forward economies
if it were up to government all you
would get is slightly better versions
maybe maybe over time of an old crappy
mousetrap
now henry ford famously said that if it
had been up
to other people most people when he
invented when he really
invented mass production of automobiles
in the united states he said
you know the difference between what i
did and what a lot of other people did
is
if it had been up to other people they
would produce a more efficient horse and
buggy
it takes a difference in kind it takes a
different kind of mind
to invent things we used to have respect
for inventors we used to think that what
they were doing was actually amazing and
cool
we used to idolize those people now it
seems that the people we idolize are the
people who seize wealth from those
people and punish those people
and treat those people as though they
are somehow expropriating wealth rather
than creating it
which is totally insane and
counterproductive and obviously makes
life worse for millions of people
the world over so frankly i think we
should be celebrating the fact that jeff
bezos went to space yesterday i think we
should be celebrating the fact that
richard
branson went to space i'd love to fly to
space at some point and the only way
that's going to happen
is not by some government program the
only way that's going to happen is if
these three people
continue to compete at high levels and
continue to bring the price down on this
sort of stuff
that's when you're going to have the
opportunity to fly to space which by the
way could actually
wildly reduce the the time that you have
to travel for example across the planet
i could widely reduce the prices that
you have on other products
space is a resource the fact that
americans are
typically leading that resource race is
a very very good thing and the fact that
you don't have to spend money on it
is an unabashedly good thing so i'm
if you couldn't tell i'm pretty
enthusiastic about all of this
and i think that everyone should be
enthusiastic as well it's a story of
american exceptionalism that we are able
to produce
so much wealth in this country via
products and services that people
voluntarily want to buy
that somebody can then take that and
then do something as cool as going to
space and reopening an entire industry
that was basically moribund for the last
couple of
decades pretty impressive stuff did you
know that every single like creates one
additional leftist here that is just
science
[Music]
ugh